The Arrowverse is expanding, again.
In October 2019, The CW announced it had put
into development another Superman-centric
TV series, this one entitled Superman & Lois.
As reported by Deadline, the series is being
written by Todd Helbing, the executive producer
of the Arrowverse series The Flash.
Greg Berlanti, who has been instrumental in
shaping the current landscape of the DC Comics
television world, is on board as executive
producer.
This new series will fill a void being left
behind as the inaugural Arrowverse series,
Arrow, finishes off its final season.
With the other shows in the Arrowverse getting
older, the show will join newer CW series
such as Black Lightning and Batwoman in carrying
superhero stories forward on the network in
the years to come.
This all-new story is actually quite familiar.
Superman and Lois Lane have been having adventures
on TV for decades, as far back as 1952 in
Adventures of Superman.
But while the upcoming series may have a long
legacy behind it, that doesn't mean it won't
still be trying to carve out something that
feels modern and fresh.
"Blah, blah, blah.
That's a bit much, don't you think?"
"Honey?"
"...Yes, dear?"
Here's what we know so far.
News broke of the show's development in October
2019, and no release date has been announced.
So we don't know exactly when we'll see one
of pop culture's oldest couples back together
on their very own show.
If the development of Batwoman is anything
to go by, the earliest we might see the series
premiere would be in late 2020, in time for
the holidays.
News that Kate Kane would be getting her own
TV series first emerged in summer 2018; her
show launched the following fall.
If history is any indicator, Superman & Lois
might be ready to launch by the end of this
year.
Superman & Lois will be welcoming two familiar
faces from the Arrowverse to its cast.
Tyler Hoechlin is returning to don the iconic
Superman cape, while Elizabeth "Bitsie" Tulloch
is reprising her role as Lois Lane.
The pair have established their onscreen chemistry
together with multiple appearances in the
Arrowverse's recent crossover events, "Elseworlds"
and "Crisis on Infinite Earths."
Now, like the Legends of Tomorrow, the Flash,
and Batwoman before them, they're finally
getting a shot to spin off on a show of their
own.
Taking to Instagram to tease his involvement
with Superman & Lois, Hoechlin gushed,
"I could not be more grateful for the opportunity
to tell this story [...] I couldn't ask for
a better partner than @BitsieTulloch in all
of this.
[...] Thank you to everyone that said 'yes'
to this project.
We won't let you down."
It's probably a safe bet that other characters
from the Arrowverse may make appearances on
Superman & Lois.
But while the crossover potential for the
series is sky-high, no plans for how it might
look were immediately revealed.
If all you've seen of Superman lately have
been his appearances in recent movies, you
might be surprised at the softer side of him
you're likely to see on this show.
Supes may be one of the strongest superheroes
around, but when he's off the clock, he's
also just a nice, sweet guy from Kansas who
likes to take care of people.
The series is said to follow Clark Kent and
Lois Lane as they balance their private lives
as parents with their professional lives as
journalists — as well as Clark's crime-fighting
career while moonlighting as the Man of Steel,
obviously.
Though no specific plot for Superman & Lois
has been confirmed by the CW, it'll likely
feel somewhat similar to the '90s reincarnation
of the couple in Lois & Clark: The New Adventures
of Superman.
That series focused more on the couple's relationship
than Superman's crime-fighting, and we imagine
that dynamic will be similar here.
Only this time, there will be the pitter-patter
of baby feet to contend with as well.
While she couldn't reveal much else about
the show's plot, Tulloch did speak briefly
to TVGuide about Superman & Lois, teasing
that the story is something quite special:
The actress said,
"When Todd Helbing was telling me about the
story for the pilot script for Superman & Lois
I got chills.
It's so good, and it's something we haven't
seen before with them, so I think it's going
to be great."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.